olá
pois é quem é que passa na cabeça de um
cara que era diretor fernando de noronha
recebia na sua casa a mulher mais bonita
do brasil é fernanda lima
maitê proença 1 e os bonitos homem
também né o de santoro fico na minha
casa várias vezes era um empresário da
noite em recife
talvez até é sem querer fazer nenhuma
elogia o próprio mas talvez tenha feito
nos anos 90 e começo dos anos 2000 as
melhores casas noturnas de recife
aqui se tem alguém mais velho que
freqüenta a noite recifense vai lembrar
do coluna café do planeta maluco do
calypso é do frida e outras casas e de
repente um a tarde de quinta-feira o dia
30 de janeiro de 2004 recebi um
telefonema dizendo que a economia sofreu
um assalto e que foi baleado no assalto
bom é é a primeira reação claro é de
correr lá para o hospital da restauração
ao saber que não é com a gravidade do
fato e como ela estava e aí é embora ela
ter levado ela tenha levado um tiro na
medula ela estava com se estava
conseguindo falar né e pediu para levá
lá é para um hospital o memorial e e me
avisaram que ela vem pra lá eu fui lá
toya irmã também é médico e foi comigo
né paraná postal e quando ela chegou a
primeira reação quando ela viu meu irmão
foi dizer que estava sentindo as pernas
então aí o mundo começou a desabar já e
48 horas passaram nesta terça duas horas
e aí o método disseram que a situação
era muito grave
ela passou 40 dias nem entre a vida ea
morte na uti é porque abala a bala pegou
também o risco é pegou fígado
e foi assim foi um uma batalha nome né
e aí recife
nos anos 90 no começo dos anos 2000
recife é a capital mais violenta do
brasil é pra quem que entendo que essa é
na na saúde cimed taxa de mortalidade na
segurança é na educação ideb e na
segurança taxa de homicídios em si uma
taxa de homicídio e 70 para 100 mil é
para cada sete homicídios para cada
grupo de 100 mil pessoas
e aí eu comecei não tinha nada a ver
como eu falei não tem nada a ver com
essa história da é de segurança na
academia e os de administração da
empresa não tinha preocupação nenhuma
com a questão da violência nem com a
segurança pública e comecei a estudar
não é porque recife na cidade tão
violenta que se matava e se morria tanto
é principalmente com arma de fogo e com
jovens envolvidos jovem 16 a 25 anos 27
anos de idade
a gente vivia no recife uma guerra civil
não declarada
amigos meus nem assaltados outras
pessoas de famílias que o conheciam
também é fita da violência latrocínio
médico foi barbaramente assassinado num
na avenida perto da avenida boa viagem e
é o jornal do comércio é um dos
principais jornais de pernambuco
publicou um caderno sobre bogotá na
colômbia
publicou o caderno e eu sei conhecer
absolutamente ninguém na colômbia é a
história que a gente ouve nacional da
colômbia é a história de pablo escobar é
da matança da de narcotráfico de cartéis
agora mesmo que entre assistindo a essa
série está passando com um vai demorar
natos
dá pra entender bem o que é que era a
colômbia é dos anos 80 dos anos 90 e até
o começo dos anos 2000 no caso de
medellín e eu quando fui pra colômbia eu
fui na ânsia de querer entender um pouco
o que era aqui que estava fazendo na
área de segurança
aí foi a primeira vez nem assim ficava
assim mas eu queria saber qual o plano
de você de segurança né
não ter um plano de segurança a
gente tem uma coisa muito mais ampla
muito mais
profunda do que é um plano simplesmente
de segurança
e aí é a primeira questão assim que que
se se leva nem que se coloca pra lá se
reverter a escalada de violência na
cidade é saber qual a cidade que nós
queremos porque a violência começou a
aprender com os colombianos que a
violência não é somente um problema da
polícia
a gente tem aí nessa imagem é que tá
todo mundo já deve ter visto já é um
bairro um condomínio de alto luxo em são
paulo e segregado com uma favela
os moradores privado dos seus direitos
básicos de educação de saúde e área de
lazer
e essa estátua que nós queremos as
idades igual a um dos filhos os filhos
dos pobres brincam nas palafitas e os
filhos do rio brinca dos melhores
parques essa foto é lá em recife
quem conhece bem disse saber que a gente
tem um parque na espetacular na zona
norte zona mais rica da cidade da
jaqueira e de lado não é bem perto do
recife temos as palafitas ali é ao longo
do rio capibaribe
nessa cidade desigual é uma cidade
geradora de violência na cidade violenta
na cidade que as pessoas fazem justiça
com as próprias mãos
temos um dos que é um meio de transporte
público da cidade mal educada onde o
pobre à classe média ea classe alta
jogam lixo no chão onde o carro da
guarda municipal e se a foto é de recife
onde o carro da guarda municipal que é o
primeiro a dar o exemplo é o primeiro a
dar o exemplo contrário é de que não
deve parar nem que seja por um segundo
na vaga do deficiente da pessoa que tem
dificuldade de locomoção
isso se reproduz na cidade essa
violência porque as pessoas não param na
faixa do pedestre
coloco o carro em cima da calçada como
se a calçada fosse uma um havia privada
dele
de que a jogam lixo é pelo pela pela
janela do carro né que não sabem é
mediam conflito no trânsito quando
alguém dá uma fechada lá e termina
xingando e aí quem vai vai querer fazer
justiça com as próprias mãos é essa
cidade que a gente quer
a cidade tem a sensibilidade das pessoas
de um dificuldade de locomoção não
possam é essa sensibilidade aos aos
transporte público nas calçadas das vias
da cidade né a cidade retorna agora
mesmo ministério público é que eu tenho
um respeito muito grande pelo ministério
público mas o ministério público de são
paulo é muito a prefeitura de são paulo
porque tava é devolvendo a cidade para
as pessoas vendida paulista fechada para
os carros de domingo e aí a grande
pergunta se essa cidade é possível e aí
eu aprendi com média lindo
principalmente em bogotá e medellín mas
principalmente como ele na colômbia que
terminou resultando na construção desse
livro é uma cidade que estava
literalmente um inferno na terra em
medellín eu falei aqui que existe uma
taxa de homicídio e 70 para 100 mil é a
capital mais violenta do brasil nos anos
90 média lixo uma taxa de homicídio de
381 pra 100 mil
nesse recolher mais os corpos das
pessoas que eram mortas na cidade
tudo absolutamente tudo se fechava em
medellín a partir das 18 horas na
faculdade não funcionava à noite as
escolas públicas não tinha é vida
noturna
os bares boates não funcionavam mais em
função é dessa dessa carnificina que
existia na cidade incomodados e em claro
por pablo escobar é que só num ano
matava ele dava mil pagava mil a 5 mil
dólares para cada policial mundo
dependendo da patente era mais dólares
mataram 66 policiais no ano somente na
cidade de medellín
e essa cidade saiu literalmente do
inferno recebeu o prêmio há dois anos
atrás de cidade inovadora do mundo né
pelas inovações sociais na educação de
qualidade para o público
é para sua população e aí a realidade de
medellín é diferente da realidade nossa
aqui essa foto mostra muito bem aí uma
foto lá de medellín é a esquerda uma
foto lá no rio de janeiro e outra foto
aqui em recife são muito parecidas
realidades porque a gente é muito levado
a buscar é é experiências naná estados
unidos na europa não tudo bem é muito
bom buscar experiências em países
desenvolvidos mas a gente precisa
enxergar um país vizinho aqui ao nosso
que tem as mesmas dificuldades que o
brasil tem que ter as mesmas
desigualdade que o brasil tem que tem as
mesmas funções policiais e de políticos
como o brasil tem mais esse país tá
dando a volta por cima e dois
componentes o importantíssimo nessa
virada de medellín em bogotá a primeira
a mais importante delas a decisão
política é um gestor público é tem que
tomar a decisão política de enxergar
cidade uma cidade para todos é que as
políticas públicas sejam estabelecidos
principalmente para aqueles que mais
necessitam na cidade é que são as
populações vulneráveis né
os pobres as pessoas que vivem nas
favelas
as crianças que não têm uma escola
porque deficiente lá no seu território é
essa foi a principal decisão política
dos gestores públicos de bogotá e
medellín para reverter a escalada da
violência e criar condições de igualdade
no território no espaço público
a segunda então também não menos
importante que a gente está agora
discutindo aqui no brasil só a cidade
para as pessoas
eu adoro o carro no adoro carro mas
carrega como geladeira é quando você
compra um carro você vai dizer o governo
vai colocar seu carro a mesma coisa com
a geladeira é a mesma coisa com a roupa
que a gente compra é um problema da
gente de saber é aonde vai colocar a
geladeira onde vai colocar a roupa se
reencontrou na loja de grife ou em
qualquer outro local
a gente tem que devolver a a a cidade
para as pessoas né e o primeiro é o
primeiro a primeira prioridade que deve
haver são as calçadas as calçadas né o
primeiro passo para para a cidadania
no lugar no espaço público onde não se
respeita as calçadas não se respeitam
absoluto se respeita absolutamente mais
nada né então essa é uma grande lição
não é que a colômbia é particularmente
que bogotá e medellín estão dando para o
mundo inteiro que prevê que é possível
se revertesse ela da violência que é
possível sim né é a oferecer à população
mais pobre mais vulnerável da cidade das
melhores escolas as melhores bibliotecas
pública os melhores meios de transporte
e claro sim uma polícia nem que respeita
o direito do cidadão mais uma polícia
equipada que é valorizada é pelo setor
público e que é reconhecida pelo cidadão
colombiano é hoje hoje em délhi
'nesse você pega qualquer literatura
internacional sobre modelo de gestão da
cidade vai estar lá medellín como
referência e recentemente uma jornalista
da folha de são paulo silva colombo
muito respeitada aqui no brasil esteve
na colômbia esteve em medellín e
escreveu lá uma reportagem de uma página
inteira e retrata retrata nessa página o
que é ela fez é o que ela viu lá em
bogotá
e aí pra finalizar eu deixo essa essa
mensagem aqui pra vocês que a questão da
segurança pública no enfrentamento à
violência urbana é tem que ser
enfrentada por todo mundo né tem que ser
enfrentada pelo governo e é preciso que
a gente cobra do governo federal do
governo do estado e dos prefeitos
municipais
mas é preciso também que a gente dê a
nossa parcela de responsabilidade
rio era empresário da noite como falei
pra vocês têm um carro diretor da ilha
de fernando de noronha e largam tudo
para dar minha parcela de
responsabilidade pequena que seja mas
que a gente possa deixar lá na cidade do
recife um trabalho é que no futuro a
gente possa dizer para os nossos filhos
nossos netos que a gente vai ter uma
cidade mais justa mais humana e mais
decente para se viver
muito obrigado